Chris Rock toe you make specials a
masterpiece yeah you try to yeah because
they have longevity they you don't want
to make them something that that's
almost a sculpturing thing that we've
talked about yeah yeah yeah specials are
some mitts to me I used to describe it
like the way they make samurai swords or
used to that they bang it and then fold
it and then bang it again and then they
fold it and keep banging it so you know
they pound on it and they fold it so
that they're squeezing out all the all
the oxygen that's in the you know what I
mean just keep making it perfect so
every time you think I've got an hour no
you don't write another hour and then
fold that into that one and and then get
real all the impurities and all the bad
stuff and then keep doing that I had a
lot of process I used to do like
everything that was my quote you know
your big closing bit your closing bit
can make you very sluggish you know kind
of lazy because about twenty minutes
into your set you're like I'm you know
use a 60-minute set usually or maybe
ninety yeah so like 20 minutes in you're
now 20 minutes away from your big 20
minute closer which you know is not
gonna place those 20 minutes well if you
got a really good strong work so but so
20 minutes in you're like I can coast
for 20 minutes because I could got this
thing yeah so I started making life hard
for myself by opening with the closer
like let's open with the hardest
material and then now I'm in a much
worse a then you got a long way to go
yeah then I have to follow it I have to
follow my toughest material with stuff
that's pretty weak and I have no closer
I have nothing to depend on there's just
an open wound at the end so but if I did
that then this bit would just through
need it would corner eyes and become the
closer and then you put that at the
beginning and you keep doing that until
you have hopefully 90 minutes of closing
bits where you could just flop them out
and doesn't matter whatever that ought
to be a prescription for everybody
should be able to take a hard look and
make sure you're not coasting and turn
it up sundown I mean somebody once said
about a business model you got to blow
it up every 10 years right you might as
well I mean well it would be the point
of doing this kind of crazy stuff if
you're not trying to really do your the
best version of yours can you imagine
doing something in five years not
whether it's under the broad umbrella of
comedy and film entertaining but can you
imagine doing something that you just
would never occur to you today I mean is
there is part of your mindset today
being as successful as you are I want to
really push the boundaries in the
frontiers of whatever well I'd love to
do new things I love to learn
learning is my favorite thing so if
something came across I don't look at my
career as like I want to do the biggest
thing so like if I get offered something
that's like you're gonna be the
blockbuster you're gonna be the you know
the this you know proneness animal suit
and be this guy you're gonna get paid
fifty trillion dollars I wouldn't to me
that's not interesting but something
yeah I mean I don't know what it is if
somebody said it they want you to go do
this yes I would I'm excited
that's where your head is yeah like
maybe somebody will say go to Hungary
and make a TV station in hungry all
right I'll try it by that yeah